let's talk a little bit about how you
guys are gaining that exposure and then
we could talk more I think about just
institutional investors in general but
sorting with you guys so your investors
in gbtc then you invest in a number of
other businesses almost exclusively in
the public markets and those publicly
traded companies maybe something like a
square that has a number of different
products or kind of revenue streams one
of them could be Bitcoin right so you
almost get like indirect exposure to
Bitcoin through a business that benefits
from Bitcoin as a product or something
that they offer and then combine that
with the gbtc you're really kind of
getting exposure in multiple ways that
correct that's exactly right so there
are definitely public companies that
offer interesting derivatives Bossier to
crypto and you know square is actually
one of our highest conviction names
where you know squares primary business
model has nothing really necessarily to
do with Bitcoin or crypto but when you
actually dig deep into potential kind of
revenue streams down the line you start
to realize how interesting any
opportunities they're there there are so
actually part of our research and part
of our thesis is that you have these
technology platforms that are kind of
converging and so the idea of having
like a traditional tech analyst or
traditional OTO analyst or traditional
energy analyst in this new world does
not necessarily fit and so when you kind
of look at like a company like square
there's so many kind of different ways
where you can tackle the investment
pieces so obviously the one that a lot
of snow is kind of a high level you have
these retail banks that pay between you
know 350 and 1,500 dollars to partner
customers and you you contrast that with
a company like square which has one of
the most you know popular digital
wallets in the cash app which has a
customer acquisition cost of around 20
dollars and so this goes back actually
to one of Arc's overarching theses which
is around this idea that cost declines
are a primary force behind
technologically enabled disruption and
so the same holds true in consumer
making and so our
our FinTech analyst so I actually cover
square and stop butter FinTech analyst
max Friedrich has done incredible work
on how this kind of unlocks a massive
market where you say that there's let's
say 20 million people in the US we're
still unbanked to put this kind of into
perspective you know Citibank has 20
million customer accounts in the u.s.
today and we use what's really
interesting to see is when you see the
comparison of the FDIC's on bank rates
and we will search friends for squares
cash up which can max that a lot of work
on there's a very compelling kind of
Geographic overlap that that makes that
makes it such that you know cash at
dominates the southern states where the
rates of the unbanked are highest you
have kind of these features like direct
deposit which Square introduced in 2018
that lets cash app users generate these
kind of routing and account numbers that
you would kind of get in normal checking
accounts and then they can then pass
that on to to facilitate the deposit to
their own employers and you can
basically spend paychecks from your cash
at balance with a debit card that cash
at issues and so when you combine that
with an extremely savvy network based
marketing strategy with a clear product
roadmap you basically come to what could
be a fully functional digital bag
they've built a robust user base
targeting specific consumer networks you
have extremely sticky p2p payments and
and so there's a growing realization
that that most banking functions can
basically mark migrate it to your iPhone
notice how none of that Bitcoin that
Bitcoin ever really come up and so then
you layer on top of that you know
something like Bitcoin where you look at
Jack Dorsey as being the only CEO I
would say the two public companies that
truly understands bitcoins value
proposition and I've said it before and
I'll say it again I think that we can't
underestimate the role kind
square and Jack are playing and kind of
bringing Bitcoin to the masses and there
are a few interesting angles that Square
has taken and it's involved in Bitcoin
that I think is very unique I mean at
one level you have let's say you know
the cash app providing an you know easy
interface to buy sell send Bitcoin and
and you know what's interesting is that
the cash up isn't like a big point first
product and so it's almost like oh by
the way there is a another Avenue by
which you can learn about Bitcoin and
it's through the cash shop and you
already have to catch up battle it on
your phone and so there's this
educational on-ramp and and normalizing
a Bitcoin that I think that Square is
doing that many people don't yet realize
and then on the on the flip side of that
you have something like you know a year
ago where we're square set up let's say
square crypto and that is basically a
separate corporate entity whose really
sole function is to sponsor Bitcoin
developers and further the Bitcoin
ecosystem so kinda foregoing short-term
profits for kind of the the the benefit
of Bitcoin and so having a public
company and that has to appeal to ships
Terran shareholders that then
acknowledges that you know ultimately
we're long-term investors and Bitcoin
success squares success is is a really
really interesting kind of angle that I
think that very few public companies
have the foresight to to take and so
when you combine that with the fact that
Square also has access to millions of
merchants they could end up
hypothetically cutting out card networks
entirely if you have both the customer
and the merchant we're on board and in
doing so that using potentially Bitcoin
as a settlement layer and so there are
several layers to this so that that's
kind of how we view you Square more
broadly and I think that you know it's a
very very interesting unique way of
getting kind of that derivative exposure
to the Bitcoin opportunity